This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人出品。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个节目探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都觉得不太安全却又必须进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人背负着一副重铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你非得去抗下所有，听听看。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方，收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trapped）。我是斯科茨代尔警局的劳拉。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方，收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇异的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即TWA percent，在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
相信你的闺蜜。收听《相信闺蜜》（Trust me, babe, babe），在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时经历的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Co-dependency is a word that gets thrown around a lot in the self-help space, but it's also incredibly misunderstood. do it. And a lot of us don't really understand the pattern of behaviors it describes. We also tend to believe that we would be really good at recognizing codependency when we see it. We think of someone who lacks boundaries around others, who is incredibly emotionally, sometimes physically dependent on other people. But what about those situations when codependency doesn't look like the
很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们要一如既往地剖析二十岁的心理学。“共情依赖”或“共依存”是自助领域中经常被提及的一个词，但它也被严重误解了。大家都在这么做。我们中的很多人其实并不理解它所描述的行为模式。我们还倾向于认为，当自己看到共依存时，我们一定能非常敏锐地识别出来。我们认为这样的人往往缺乏界限感，在情感上、有时在身体上极其依赖他人。但是，当共依存并不表现为那种
codependency that we've typically come to expect? What happens when it looks like being the person that others always come to when they're in trouble, always being the one to make group plans, organize, travel, divvy up the check, never having a minute for yourself or feeling very exhausted by everyone else's emotions, needs, preferences. Could that also be codependency? We tend to really reward and praise this kind of self-sacrificing and giving behavior, and we see it as selfless, but are we really just trying to control a situation? we just feel more secure when we are in charge? All of this indicates something called high functioning codependency, which is a more invisible form of codependency, really common amongst
我们通常所期待的共依存时，情况又会怎样呢？当它表现为总是成为别人遇到麻烦时第一个找的人，总是那个负责制定集体计划、组织旅行、分摊账单的人，从来没有一分钟属于自己，或者对其他所有人的情绪、需求、偏好感到精疲力竭时，会发生什么？这难道也可能是共依存吗？我们往往会大力奖赏和赞扬这种自我牺牲和付出的行为，并将其视为无私，但我们其实只是在试图控制一个局面吗？当我们掌权时，我们会不会只是感到更有安全感？所有这一切都指向了一种叫做“高功能共依存”的现象，这是一种更隐蔽的共依存形式，在
overgiving, over extending individuals. And I want to talk about it today because it is a concept that has just fascinated me. And to talk about it, I want to welcome on the psychotherapist and the boundary expert Terry Cole, who discovered this phenomena and who talks about it a lot to people worldwide. So Terry welcome to the show. Oh, thanks for having me. I'm really, really excited. Can you give a little intro, tell people who you are before we dive into my questions for you today? Sure.
过度付出、过度延伸的人群中非常普遍。我今天想谈谈它，因为这是一个让我着迷的概念。为了探讨这个话题，我想请心理治疗师和界限专家特里·科尔作客节目，她发现了这一现象并经常向全世界的人们讲述它。特里，欢迎来到节目。哦，谢谢邀请我。我真的、真的非常兴奋。在进入我今天的问题之前，你能简单做个自我介绍，告诉大家你是谁吗？当然可以。
I am a psychotherapist and a relationship expert. I'm a boundary expert in communication. I have been doing this for 27 years. I am the author of a book called Boundary Boss. And I have a new book that's coming out in October. Actually, this drops on the 11th. So on the 15th of this month, called Too Much, a guide to break in the cycle of high functioning codependency.
我是一名心理治疗师和关系专家。我是界限与沟通专家。我从事这一行已经27年了。我是《界限老板》（Boundary Boss）一书的作者。我有一本新书将在十月出版。实际上，这期节目发布的正好是11号。所以就在本月15号，新书名为《太多了：打破高功能共依存循环指南》（Too Much, a Guide to Breaking the Cycle of High Functioning Coodependency）。
So I'm really an expert in female empowerment. Like, that's really what my deal is. I was a talent agent, negotiating contracts for supermodels and celebrities before I became a psychotherapist. So I left this career that nobody really understood why I was leaving that career. My father was like, hello, what are you doing?
所以我真的是女性赋权方面的专家。这就是我的专长。在成为心理治疗师之前，我是一名星探，为超级名模和名人谈判合同。所以我离开了这个让别人都无法理解我为什么要离开的职业。我父亲当时说，喂，你在干什么？
You're going to become a social work. Like, what? Hello? Why are you doing that? And it's interesting when you have a different career before becoming a therapist, but I was motivated by my own experience in therapy. I just couldn't even believe how much you could change your own life and that it really did not matter what cards I was dealt. Like, that shit did not determine the hand I was going to play in life. I decided, I don't like that hand. I don't even like this fucking game. I'm not even playing this game. I'm making up an entirely new game, which is what I did. but I was able to see that possibility because of my own personal evolution in therapy. And then even though I had this fancy, very shiny career that everyone thought was amazing and I was making a ton of cash, and I was in Hollywood.
你要去当社会工作者吗？就像，什么？喂？你为什么要这么做？当你成为治疗师之前从事过不同的职业时，这很有趣，但我当时的动力来自于我自己在治疗中的亲身经历。我简直不敢相信你能如此大地改变自己的生活，而且我拿到的牌是什么真的不重要。那些狗屁并没有决定我一生中要打出什么手牌。我决定，我不喜欢那手牌。我甚至不喜欢这破游戏。我连这个游戏都不玩了。我要创造一个全新的游戏，而我确实也这么做了。但我能够看到这种可能性，是因为我在治疗中获得了个人进化。尽管我当时拥有这份光鲜亮丽、每个人都觉得了不起、能赚一大笔钱、而且身处好莱坞的职业。
You know, this was New York and L.A. I was bicostal. It's like I had. It was fancy, but I wasn't happy. And you just get to a point where you can't, like I just could no longer deny that the only thing I cared about was the mental health of the model. I was like, you need to change careers, dude, because you don't even want to be here anymore doing this.
你知道，这是纽约和洛杉矶。我两头跑。就好像我拥有。这很高级，但我并不快乐。你总会达到这样一个地步，就像我再也无法否认我唯一真正关心的其实是模特的心理健康。我就想，老兄，你需要换个职业了，因为你甚至都不想呆在这里做这个了。
But I really wanted to help people. And so I was in my early 30s when I decided to become a psychotherapist, and I've been doing that for 27 years. That is an incredible story, just incredible. And honestly, it is very indicative of a calling. It's just so clear to me when you're explaining that. It's like, oh, this, yeah, it wasn't the right fit for you because there was a higher thing that, obviously maybe your soul, your personality was calling you to and now you've done some incredible, incredible work in this space.
但我真的很想帮助别人。所以我三十出头的时候决定成为一名心理治疗师，并且我已经从事这个职业27年了。这是一个不可思议的故事，简直难以置信。老实说，这非常能说明一种天职。当你这样解释时，我对这一点看得非常清楚，就像，哦，这个，是的，它并不完全适合你，因为有一个更高的使命，显然可能是你的灵魂，你的个性在召唤你，现在你在这一领域做出了令人难以置信的伟大工作。
What initially, so you wrote this incredible book on boundaries, which really I would recommend. You also wrote an amazing YouTube channel and I was reading some of the comments on a video that you did around boundaries and the amount of people who are like, wow, like my eyes are suddenly open to an entirely new reality. I think that is the power of talking about mental health, talking about psychology, embracing therapy. What drew you to codependency in the same way that you were initially drawn into this space? The reason, I'll just share quickly, like, why did I come up with
最初，你写了这本关于界限的不可思议的书，我真的强烈推荐。你还运营着一个精彩的YouTube频道，我当时在看你关于界限的一段视频下的一些评论，有很多人说，哇，我的双眼突然睁开，看到了一个全新现实。我认为这就是谈论心理健康、谈论心理学、拥抱治疗的力量。是什么吸引你走向共依存，就像你最初被吸引到这个领域一样？原因嘛，我简单分享一下，我为什么会提出
high functioning codependency? Why? Was there not enough on codependency? Well, the answer is, there wasn't. And it wasn't the right stuff for my clients. So what I saw over and over again is that I have these baller women who are CFOs, I mean international pop star, like people who are crushing the game of life. And not all. And then some would say at home moms, which are amazing too, right?
高功能共依存？为什么？难道关于共依存的讨论还不够多吗？好吧，答案是，确实不够。而且对于我的客户来说，那些内容并不合适。所以我一次又一次看到的是，我有这些非常优秀的女性客户，她们是CFO，甚至是国际流行巨星，就像那些在生活这场游戏中大获成功的人。虽然不是全部。还有一些人说是全职妈妈，这也是了不起的职业，对吧？
Not everyone had huge careers, but a lot did. And I use them as an example because so much of the time people will look at someone who's a CFO of a company and making $2.5 million a year and be like, obviously they have it all together. And yet, when I would say,
并不是每个人都有宏大的职业生涯，但很多人确实有。我用她们作为例子，因为很多时候，人们会看到某个公司的CFO年薪250万美元，就会觉得她们显然把一切都安排得井井有条。然而，每当我向
to any one of those people, hey, what you're describing in your relationship is a codependent pattern. That's what I'm seeing. They would immediately reject it and be like, yeah, lady, I'm not dependent on squat. Everybody's dependent on me. I'm making all the money. I'm making all the moves. I'm controlling all the people. I'm managing everything in the home. I'm managing all the kids. I'm my family of origin. I'm organizing all the shit. So they couldn't see. So I realized, oh, my clients don't know what codependency is. So what happened is they were stuck in the old school melody-bedee codependent no more. You have to be enabling an alcoholic in order to be a codependent.
其中任何一个人指出，嘿，你在恋爱关系中描述的其实是一种共依存模式。这就是我看到的。她们会立刻拒绝，并说，得了吧，女士，我才不依赖任何人呢。所有人都依赖我。我赚所有的钱。我做所有的决策。我控制所有的人。我管理家里的每一件事。我管理所有的孩子。我是我原生家庭的主心骨。我组织所有的破事。所以她们自己看不出来。所以我意识到，哦，我的客户并不知道什么是共依存。所以发生的情况是，她们陷入了老派的梅洛迪·贝蒂（Melody Beattie）《不再共依存》（Codependent No More）的观念中。你必须在纵容一个酗酒者，才能算是一个共依存者。
And that just is not accurate. It just isn't true, you know? So when I added high functioning to go-dependency and explain to my clients what it is when you are overly invested in the feeling states, the outcomes, right? the relationships, the finances, the feelings, all of it, of the people in your life to the detriment of your own internal peace. Right. And we need that caveat because it's not the same. Of course, we're all invested in the people we love being happy, obviously.
而这根本不准确。这根本不是真的，你知道吗？所以当我把“高功能”加到共依存前面，并向我的客户解释到底什么是高功能共依存——当你过度投入到你生活中的人们的情感状态、结果、关系、财务、情绪以及这一切当中，以牺牲你自己的内心的平静为代价。没错。我们需要这个前提，因为这并不一样。当然，我们都希望我们爱的人能够快乐，这很显然。
We're like normal, nice people. When you're a high functioning codependent, it's more than that. It's like we feel compelled to take it on. We feel actually responsible for. other people's feeling states and their outcomes. And at its, you know, when I added the high functioning to the definition, my clients, all of them, without shame, raise their hands saying it's me, I'm the problem, it's me. Not to quote Taylor, but I will.
我们就像正常、善良的人一样。当你是一个高功能共依存者时，情况远不止于此。这就好像我们感到自己有义务去承担这一切。我们实际上觉得自己对其他人的情绪状态和他们的结果负有责任。而且当它（你知道的），当我把“高功能”这个词加入定义时，我的客户们，所有这些人，都毫无羞愧地举起手说，是我，我就是那个问题所在，我就是问题。虽然不是在引用泰勒（·斯威夫特）的话，但我确实想这么说。
Please, go for it. You know what I mean, though, where they felt like that's true. I am overfunctioning. I am overgiving. I do do more than my share. I am doing all the emotional labor in my home, and I am pissed because that's the thing. You could do that for a long time. Sooner or later, that shit is a one-way ticket to bitter land.
请便，说下去吧。但你知道我的意思，他们觉得确实如此。我正在过度发挥功能。我正在过度付出。我确实做了超出我分内的事。我在家里承担了所有的情感劳动，而且我很生气，因为这就是关键所在。你可以这样坚持很长时间。但迟早，这种破事是一张通往痛苦之地的单程票。
Like, there's only so long you can do it. You know what I mean? Absolutely. And it was interesting when I was looking into this where just how much I resonated with this concept, where you get into this mindset of being like, I'm giving so much, but you realize that actually all that you're allowing, in that process of giving, actually, you're just allowing boundaries to be crossed for the sake of others.
就像，你只能坚持那么久。你知道我的意思吗？绝对是这样。当我深入研究这个概念时，觉得很有趣，我发现自己与这个概念产生了多么强烈的共鸣：你陷入了一种心态，觉得自己付出了那么多，但你意识到，实际上你在付出的过程中所允许的一切，不过是为了他人而允许界限一次次被跨越。
And you don't realize that actually you are assuming that you are giving people everything, everything for them and that you are doing what's best for them. But actually they would be better off if you had stronger boundaries. They would actually be better off if you were more able to not just say no, but to have like entire systems in place in the first place and expectations around what they could come to you for, what you were able to do, the time you needed for yourself. And as you said, when you add that high functioning component, I think that also reduces some of the perhaps stigma around codependency, that codependency is only about people who just
而你并没有意识到，其实你以为自己是在为人们付出一切，为他们做着最好的安排，但实际上，如果你有更强烈的界限感，他们反而会过得更好。如果你不仅能说“不”，而且从一开始就拥有一套完整的系统和期望——关于他们能找你做什么、你能够做到什么、以及你需要多少属于自己的时间——他们其实会过得更好。正如你所说，当你加入这个高功能成分时，我认为这也减少了人们对共依存的一些污名化，即共依存只是关于那些
want to spend a lot of time with each other or only about people who enable substance use it's actually not the case. It shows up in a lot of very, as you said, high achieving women, high achieving individuals who are perhaps using codependency as a way to stay secure and stay in control of other people's feelings and therefore their own feelings. So what are some of the typical indicators if you were talking to a therapy client and you said to them, oh, you know, I think that high functioning codependency is something that you might relate to. what would you describe to them? What kind of individual would you describe to them?
只想花大量时间黏在一起的人，或者只是关于那些纵容物质滥用的人，但事实并非如此。正如你所说，它表现在许多非常成功的女性、非常成功的人身上，她们或许把共依存作为一种保持安全感、掌控他人感受从而掌控自己感受的方式。那么，如果你在跟一位心理治疗客户交谈，并且对他们说：“哦，你知道吗，我觉得高功能共依存可能是你会产生共鸣的一个概念。”你会有哪些典型的描述指标呢？你会向他们描述一个怎样的人？
Well, I think, yes, I would describe to them, which I would describe to you, the traits, and then we would hit the behaviors, and then we would hit the costs, and then we could hit what you can do about it, right? How we can change it. So let's do it in that order, shall we? Yes, please. Traits, feeling responsible for fixing other people's problems, giving till it hurts, right, going above and beyond, even when you're not asked to.
嗯，我想，是的，我会向他们描述特质——我也会向你描述这些，然后我们会讲到行为，然后我们会讲到代价，最后我们可以讲讲你能做些什么，对吧？我们如何改变它。那我们就按这个顺序来，好吗？好的，请讲。特质包括：觉得有责任解决别人的问题，付出到心痛为止，对吧？超越本分去付出，即使别人根本没要求你这么做。
And a lot of times, a lot of the shit I was doing my 20s, nobody was asking. And I still felt underappreciated for it. Always ready to jump into damage control mode. Like at the ready for any crisis, we are the friend that you want to be in the foxhole with because we're good in a crisis. A kind of being a little judgy of others, because deep down, we really kind of think we know what they should be doing. We're a little bit like, if Betty had just listened to me and broken up with that idiot six months ago, she wouldn't be crying right now. we can get a little self-righteous. Getting frustrated and angry.
而且很多时候，我在二十多岁时做的那些破事，根本没人要求我做。但我仍然觉得自己为此付出的努力没有得到赏识。总是随时准备进入危机控制模式。面对任何危机都严阵以待，我们就是那种你想和他在战壕里並肩作战的朋友，因为我们在危机中表现出色。对别人有点评判性，因为在内心深处，我们真的觉得自己知道他们该做些什么。我们会有点像，如果贝蒂早六个月听我的话跟那个白痴分手，她现在就不会哭了。我们会变得有点自以为是。当别人不采纳我们优质的建议时，就会感到沮丧和愤怒。
When other people don't take our grade A advice. Feeling exhausted, resentful, bitter, burnt out. So those are traits. Behaviors. Well, auto advice giving. Just giving unsolicited advice to any and all who will listen. Being overly self-sacrificing. again, as you just kind of described, like doing all the things for other people.
当其他人不接受我们A级的建议时。感到精疲力竭、充满怨恨、痛苦、筋疲力尽。所以这些都是特质。至于行为方面：首先是自动给出建议。总是向所有愿意听的人主动提供未经请求的建议。过度自我牺牲。再次强调，正如你刚才所描述的，为别人做所有的事情。
Auto-accommodating. So I want to talk about this concept that I also originated because it was something that I suffered from. I was like, I cannot be the only person where this is happening. So it was a Saturday, I was in my salon in New York City, and it was super busy, and I normally don't go on Saturday because it's like a zoo in there, but anyway, I had to go. And I'm sitting there, and it's busy as hell, and I'm laying in a sink. I've got a hair mask on my hair. and now the sink traffic is starting to back up.
自动迁就。所以我想谈谈这个概念，这也是我首创的，因为这也是我曾经饱受其苦的问题。当时我想，我绝不可能是唯一一个经历这种事的人。那是星期六，我在纽约市的美发沙龙里，里面人超级多，我通常星期六不去，因为里面简直就像个动物园，但不管怎样，我那天不得不去。我坐在那里，里面忙得要命，我正把护发膜敷在头发上，此时洗头台开始排起长队。
And every time another person is standing there with a towel around their head waiting or whatever, I'm getting more and more anxious because here I am taking up a sink. But like nobody's doing anything to me, right? I'm just sitting here. I could be sitting somewhere else, but letting this mask sit. So anyway, I call over the assistant and say, hey, I could move. And of course, she's looking at me like, no shit, lady. I know you could move, but I don't need you to because I do this every Saturday. I mean, she was nice. She was like, we're good. And I had this realization. I was like, this is how you are everywhere, Tara. You're so dialed into your external environment. It feels like you are responsible for, right? I felt responsible for the sync flow for no good reason,
每当另一个人头上裹着毛巾站在那里等待或者干嘛的时候，我就会越来越焦虑，因为我正占着一个洗头台。但其实根本没有人对我说什么，对吧？我只是坐在那里。我其实可以坐在其他地方，但为了让这个发膜起作用。总之，我把助理叫过来，说，嘿，我可以让出位置。当然，她看着我的表情就像在说，废话，女士。我知道你可以让开，但我不需要你让，因为我每个星期六都这么干。我的意思是，她人很好。她就说，我们这儿挺好的。然后我突然意识到：这就是你在所有地方的为人处世方式，特拉。你对外部环境的敏感度太高了，以至于你觉得似乎所有的事都是你的责任，对吧？我觉得自己莫名其妙地对洗头台的流动顺畅负有责任，
seeing as how I was a customer as well. And I actually just, this was only five years ago. and I actually put it on, I put it on YouTube, right? I just did like a quick, like video, and it went totally viral. And people were just like, oh, my God, that is me. So auto-accommodating is when you basically see a need in your environment, and you just want to jump in and fix it. You just want to jump in and help. You just, you know, and again, a lot of people will say to me online,
考虑到我也是个顾客。其实这件事，这只是在五年前发生的。我把它发到了网上，发到了YouTube上，对吧？我只是做了一个简短的视频，结果它彻底火了。人们纷纷表示：“哦，天哪，那就是我。”所以“自动迁就”就是当你基本上在你的环境中看到某种需求时，你就只想马上跳进去解决它。你只想跳进去帮忙。你只是，你知道的，而且再次强调，很多人会在网上对我说
I mean, I'm just being nice. Like, what's wrong with being nice? And I'm like, here's the thing. If you can't not do it, you're not being nice. It is a compulsion. Oh, wow. Bit of a truth bomb there. Right, which is why the way that I walk you through it in the book and the way I walk you through it in my community is that we get into recovery from high functioning codependency.
我的意思是，我只是表现得好。比如，表现得好有什么错？而我觉得，情况是这样的。如果你无法不这样做，那你根本不是在表现得好。这是一种强迫行为。哦，哇。那可真是一个重磅炸弹。没错，这就是为什么我在书里以及我的社区里引导你时，我们会开始从高功能共依附中恢复过来。
But we don't get cured because this is a discipline to change. these behaviors takes time, you know. Other behaviors are anticipatory planning. You know, you're going to be with people. I tell a story in the book about my friend who was dating this person. It was just such a, just such a jerk. I hated this person. But anyway, but we were going away. And so her partner was coming. And this was someone who just kicked up my codependency hardcore because they were so difficult. And then they torture my friend. And it just was like a nightmare being with them. But anyway, I would make sure that if there were different rooms to stay and that they stayed in the nicest room so that he didn't complain. And I would make sure that whatever he drank, we would have that booze.
但我们并没有被治愈，因为这是一门纪律。改变这些 behaviors 需要时间，你知道的。其他行为则是预期性规划。你知道的，你要和别人在一起。我在书里讲了一个故事，关于我的一个朋友在和一个这样的人约会。这简直是个混蛋。我讨厌这个人。但不管怎样，我们要外出了。所以她的伙伴也要来。这是一个极大地激发了我的共依附情结的人，因为他们太难对付了。然后他们折磨我的朋友。和他们在一起简直就是一场噩梦。但不管怎样，我会确保如果有不同的房间可以住，他们能住在最好的房间里，这样他就不会抱怨。我还会确保无论他喝什么，我们都有那种酒。
Like, there was all these things. And I realized later, I was like, why? Just don't go away with them. You don't like this guy. But that's what anticipatory planning is. You might do it with family, right? Two people who don't like each other. You're like, well, I won't set them near each other.
诸如此类的事情有很多。我后来意识到，我在想，为什么？根本别和他们一起去度假啊。你根本不喜欢这家伙。但这就是预期性规划。你可能会对家人这样做，对吧？两个互相讨厌的人。你会想，好吧，我不会让他们坐在一起。
instead of, that's very HFC to try to, we're manipulating and we're like puppet mastering what's happening as opposed to having a conversation with the family members saying, hey, if you two can't figure it out, neither one of you were invited to Christmas, right? Like, why not, you know, talking true, just having a straight conversation. But as an HFC, usually we don't do that. We're all good girls. We're all, you know, we all want to be nice. We don't want people to think that we're not nice.
而不是像 HFC 那样去试图……我们在操纵，我们就像在操纵木偶一样控制着发生的事情，而不是去和家庭成员进行对话，说，嘿，如果你们两个搞不定，你们俩谁也别想来过圣诞节，对吧？比如，为什么不呢，你知道，说实话，进行一次直接的对话。但作为 HFC，通常我们不会这样做。我们都是好女孩。我们都是，你知道的，我们都想表现得好。我们不想让别人觉得我们不好。
Other behaviors is just overfunctioning. And the overfunctioning and underfunctioning dynamic is super common with HFCs, where I say that I could take, in my 20s, I could take a perfectly capable boyfriend and turn him into an underfunctioner in two weeks or less. Yeah, in the sense that you could take on all of his responsibilities. You could plan the dates. You could plan his life. What laundry he needs to be doing, when he needs to call his mom, whatever it is. Yes. Maybe not down to that minutia, but the truth was.
其他行为就是过度发挥功能。过度发挥功能和功能不足的动态在 HFC 中超级常见，我说过，在我二十多岁的时候，我可以把一个完全称职的男朋友在两周或更短的时间内变成一个功能不足的人。是的，意思是你承担了他所有的责任。你可以规划约会。你可以规划他的生活。他需要洗什么衣服，他什么时候需要给他妈妈打电话，无论是什么。是的。也许没有那么琐碎，但事实确实如此。
There wasn't room for them because the mantras of HFCs are like, I got it is one major mantra. We just can't stop being like, I got it. It's all good. I got it, right? Because we are so capable, though. So a lot of times we do got it, but just because you can, it doesn't mean you should all the time, you know? Or another mantra is it has to be me. It's like this belief that other people won't do it as well, won't do it the way we'll
没有他们的空间，因为 HFC 的口头禅是，比如，我来搞定，这是一个主要的口头禅。我们就是无法停止说，我来搞定。一切都好。我来搞定，对吧？因为我们确实非常有能力。所以很多时候我们确实能搞定，但仅仅因为你能做到，并不意味着你一直都应该这样做，你知道的？或者另一个口头禅是，必须是我。这就像是一种信念，别人不会做得那么好，不会按照我们的
want it done, won't do it in a timely fashion. So it's just easier to do it myself is a lot of what we're saying in our minds. So what is the cost of all this? Do you want to talk about that? I want to talk about that, but firstly, I want to just quickly ask this question. Because before we get into the cost, I really want to know what's at the root of this, because I'm listening to you talk about this and a few things have come out for me. The first one is maybe an element of perfectionism like you said. There is a sense that the only way that you can fully control an outcome is if you are beside every single behavior action, everything that leads you to the place.
想要的方式去做，不会按时完成。所以很多时候我们在心里说，不如我自己做更容易。那么这一切的代价是什么？你想谈谈这个吗？我想谈谈这个，但首先，我只想快速问这个问题。因为在我们探讨代价之前，我真的很想知道这一切的根源是什么，因为我听你谈论这个，我心里涌现出了一些东西。第一个可能是你说的完美主义的一个因素。有一种感觉，即你完全控制结果的唯一方法是你必须参与到每一个行为、每一个动作以及导致你走到这一步的一切事情中。
So the only way to control whether Christmas is going to go well is if you carefully curate the seeding plan, you make sure everyone is happy. So maybe it's perfectionism. Then I'm thinking maybe it's control, but then also like an element of people pleasing. right? I like what you said before around, is it really kindness or is it a compulsion? Like, are you actually at your core a nice person or can you just not fathom the idea of people not liking you or things not happening in the way that makes you feel safe and secure? So what is really at the root of this? Is it a combination of these three things or is there another ingredient that maybe I'm missing as well? Well, I think you are very astute because those ingredients, I mean, the foundation, of all codependency, but especially how to function in codependency, is control. It is an overt or covert bid to control other people's outcomes. We just don't want our friend marrying the stupid idiot.
所以，控制圣诞节是否会顺利进行的唯一方法是，你精心策划座位安排，确保每个人都开心。所以也许这是完美主义。然后我在想也许是控制，但同时也是一种迎合讨好。对吧？我喜欢你刚才说的，这真的是善良还是一种强迫？比如，你的核心究竟是一个善良的人，还是你根本无法想象别人不喜欢你或者事情没有按照让你感到安全和安心的方式发展？那么这一切的根源究竟是什么？这是这三件事的结合，还是有我可能遗漏的另一种成分？嗯，我觉得你非常敏锐，因为这些成分——我的意思是，所有共依附的基础，尤其是高功能共依附的基础，就是控制。这是对控制他人结果的一种公开或隐蔽的企图。我们只是不想让我们的朋友嫁给那个愚蠢的笨蛋。
We don't, we want to do everything we can to help her see the light. We don't want our partner getting fired, so we will, you know, not, we will make more money and let them flounder. You know what I mean? Like there's, we will over function to protect other people from feeling bad. Of course, ultimately, it makes them feel worse. So it doesn't really work in that way. So yes, over and underfunctioning, yes, perfectionism. But control is such a big part of it.
我们不想，我们想尽一切办法帮助她看清真相。我们不想让我们的伙伴被解雇，所以你会，你知道的，不会，我们会赚更多的钱，然后让他们去苦苦挣扎。你知道我的意思吗？就像会有这样的情况，我们会过度发挥功能来保护其他人免受痛苦。当然，归根结底，这会让他们感觉更糟。所以这种方法实际上并不管用。所以，是的，过度发挥功能和功能不足，是的，完美主义。但控制是其中很大一部分。
And because it has such a negative connotation, people don't want to identify with it, but that is absolutely what it is. We could, you know, you could call it, whatever the hell you want to call it. But that, that is what it is. we want to control other people's outcomes. But in the process of being so driven, unconsciously, so much of this is unconscious, it's like there's so much self-abandonment that goes on because we just want peace. As HFCs, we just want there to be peace in the valley.
而且因为这个词有如此负面的含义，人们不想去认同它，但它绝对就是这么回事。我们可以，你知道的，你可以叫它任何你他妈想叫的名字。但那就是，那就是本质所在。我们想要控制别人的结果。但在如此强烈的驱动过程中，在无意识的情况下——很大程度上这都是无意识的——就像有那么多的自我抛弃在发生，因为我们只想要平静。作为 HFC，我们只希望山谷里能有一片安宁。
We just want everyone to be happy, right? We just don't want any problems. And so that kind of peace, like we won't say anything. You know, what's her name? Shera Richardson has a great quote that it's like, you know, not speaking up to keep the peace starts of war within ourselves.
我们只希望每个人都开心，对吧？我们只是不想有任何问题。所以那种平静，比如我们什么都不会说。你知道的，叫什么名字来着？希拉·理查森有一句很好的名言，大意是，你知道的，为了保持平静而选择沉默，会在我们内心引发一场战争。
That is spot on. Spot on. I've got another question for that, actually. Sure. Because you're saying control, and I feel like this is my own personal therapy session, right? Because control is my big problem. Yes.
这真是太对了。太对了。其实我还有一个问题。当然。因为你在谈论控制，我觉得这就像是我自己的个人心理治疗课程，对吧？因为控制是我的大问题。是的。
Is there, have you found, that there is an overlap or maybe a correlation between people with high functioning codependency and those of us who are eldest daughters or people who are the eldest sibling who have perhaps been socialized and conditioned to take on all this responsibility the same way that maybe a mother would or maybe someone in charge of the family would. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
你是否发现，患有高功能共依附的人与我们这些长女，或是那些作为长兄长姐、可能已经被社会化和规训得去承担所有这些责任的人之间，存在着某种重叠或关联？这种责任就像母亲可能会承担的那样，或者就像家族负责人的那种责任一样。2%。当旁边还有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例是2%。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中的心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side,
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是 TWO%。请在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在 Look Back at It 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析其来龙去脉，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日子的。包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客，大谈 80 年代的快克毒品。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
坦白说，84 年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人而言。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at It。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核学习》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍然在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢和输。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要。你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。
Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《硬核学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实对话。打开你免费的 IHeart Radio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant.
发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中前后矛盾的惊人之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天呐，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Have you found that there is an overlap or maybe a correlation between people with high functioning codependency and those of us who are eldest daughters? Yeah, without a doubt, a lot of eldest daughter syndrome, but also a lot of good girl syndrome. Yeah. So in any, any place that you are in the family system, because if you think about family systems,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。请在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。你是否发现，患有高功能共依附的人与我们这些长女之间，存在着某种重叠或关联？是的，毫无疑问，有很多长女综合征，但也有很多好女孩综合征。是的。所以在任何地方，你在家庭系统中的任何位置，因为如果你想想家庭系统，
right, there's all these different roles that people play. And everyone was from some kind of a disordered family system. I mean, who wasn't? So if my family system, my father was a high-functioning alcoholic. So, you know, had a great job, a great career, retired at 50. Like, I mean, you know, did well, but it doesn't change what, you know, how he managed his emotions was with alcohol. And, you know, we were raised to be good girls.
对吧，人们扮演着各种不同的角色。每个人都来自某种紊乱的家庭系统。我的意思是，谁不是呢？所以在我的家庭系统中，我父亲是一个高功能酗酒者。所以，你知道的，有一份好工作，伟大的职业，50 岁退休。我的意思是，你知道的，过得很好，但这并不能改变，你知道的，他如何用酒精来管理自己的情绪。而且，你知道的，我们被抚养着要做好女孩。
And the focus, when you have a, there are different ways that the family systems are. in a family system where there is addiction of any kind, most people in the family system are organizing around that person. So in a healthy family system, it is child-focused. I don't mean child-obsessed. I just mean child-focused, where the activities are around what the children need. In a more dysfunctional system, the activities are around.
而且重点是，当你有一个，家庭系统有不同的形式。在一个有任何形式成瘾的家庭系统中，家庭系统中的大多数人都是围绕着那个人在运转。所以在健康的家庭系统中，它是以孩子为中心的。我不是指对孩子痴迷。我只是指以孩子为中心，活动是围绕着孩子们的需要展开的。在一个更 dysfunctional 的系统中，活动是围绕着。
It could be a designated patient, right? It could be someone with mental health, could be someone who's physically unwell, could be an abuser that people organize around, but you learn how to go along to get along. Nobody needs to send you like a note when you're seven to figure out how to avoid being rejected, how to avoid being abused.
可能是指定的病人，对吧？可能是某个心理健康有问题的人，可能是某个身体不适的人，可能是人们围着转的施虐者，但你学会了随波逐流。当你是七岁的时候，没有人需要发给你一张纸条，教你如何避免被拒绝，如何避免受到虐待。
Like you immediately know it intuitively, how to be helpful, how to go make mommy's next drink, even if mommy's an alcoholic, because you're a part of the solution and you don't want her to be mad or to judge you or to reject you. So a lot of times those things make a difference too.
就像你凭直觉立刻就能知道，如何去帮忙，如何去帮妈妈调下一杯酒，即使妈妈是个酗酒者，因为你是解决方案的一部分，而你不想让她生气、对你评头论足或拒绝你。所以很多时候，这些事情也会产生影响。
I grew up as the hero child in my family system. So that's the one where everyone can agree that that person is amazing, no matter what else is going on. But so you sort of have it on your shoulders to like make the family look good, right? Yes. Everyone can agree that you're good. You're a winner. You know what I mean?
我在我的家庭系统中是作为英雄孩子长大的。所以，这就是那种无论发生什么，每个人都一致认为这个人非常棒的角色。但所以你有点把责任扛在肩上，让家庭看起来很好，对吧？是的。每个人都同意你很好。你是个赢家。你知道我的意思吗？
But none of these roles are free. So all of the family systems, whether you're the scapegoat, whether you know what I mean, all those roles play a part. But I find that a lot of HFCs are eldest daughters or first generation or their parents were first generation. You know, there's a lot of that too because there's so much culture. I mean, we have a downloaded HFC blueprint, all of us do, which is basically your relational blueprint. And this is made up of what you learned in your family of origin, the country you grew up in the culture, the society, your role in the family system. All of these things sort of coalesce, come together. And this makes up the unconscious material that is in your mind that tells you this is the way I should relate in the world.
但这些角色没有一个是免费的。所以所有的家庭系统，无论你是替罪羊，无论你知道我的意思，所有这些角色都起着作用。但我发现很多 HFC 都是长女，或者是一代移民，或者她们的父母是一代移民。你知道的，这其中也有很多这样的情况，因为有太多的文化。我的意思是，我们所有人都下载了一个 HFC 的蓝图，基本上就是你的关系蓝图。这是由你在原生家庭中学到的东西、你长大的国家、文化、社会以及你在家庭系统中的角色所组成的。所有这些事情交织在一起，融为一体。这就构成了你脑海中无意识的材料，它告诉你这就是我在世界上建立关系的方式。
Whether it's with the people at church, whether it's with my partner, whether it's with my friends, whether it's with my cousins, whatever. right? We have a how it should be type of thing. And part of this process I'm getting healthier. And I walk people through it in Boundary Bost and we also walk through it in too much, in different, with different lenses, right? Because in too much, we're really looking at what did you learn about the way you're supposed to relate to other people in specific situations and the world, though? Because with HFCs, it's different than sort of regular codependency. Because we can get, we can become codependent with people we don't even freaking know barely. Like, because we're concerned about others. We can sort of get codependent with our environment. And people we just meet, at least I did, and I see this in my clients as well. Oh, I'm just listening to you talk about this. But you can see me just nodding my head, being like, yeah, tick, tick.
无论是与教会里的人，还是与我的伴侣，与我的朋友，与我的表亲，还是随便什么人，对吧？我们都有一种“事情本该如此”的心理。而这个过程的一部分，就是我正在变得更加健康。我在《Boundary Boss》中引导人们度过这个过程，我们在《Too Much》中也通过不同的视角来探讨这个问题，对吧？因为在《Too Much》中，我们真正审视的是：在特定的情境和世界中，你关于“自己应该如何与他人建立关系”学到了什么？因为高功能共依附（HFC）与那种常规的共依附是不同的。因为我们甚至可能对那些我们根本不怎么认识的人产生共依附。比如，因为我们太在意别人。我们甚至会与我们的环境产生某种共依附。还有那些我们刚认识的人——至少我曾经是这样，我在我的客户身上也看到了这一点。哦，我正听你谈论这个呢。但你看我一直在点头，心想：“没错，完全说中了。”
And it's interesting what you said around it being almost wide into our subconscious or unconscious. especially as children, but also coming to us almost as a blueprint. We all have this capacity. And of course, the blueprint that we all have as children comes from a place of survival. That's why we are born to be particularly accommodating to the needs of a caregiver or a parent because we are reliant on them. It's why we are born to, being able to chameleon, being able to please others, it's all survival.
而且有趣的是，你刚才提到这几乎是深深植根于我们的潜意识或无意识中的。特别是作为孩子时，这些东西也几乎是作为一种蓝图传递给我们的。我们所有人都有这种潜质。当然，我们作为孩子时拥有的蓝图源于求生本能。这就是为什么我们生来就会特别去迎合照顾者或父母的需求，因为我们依赖他们。这就是为什么我们天生就能像变色龙一样适应环境，能够去讨好他人，这全都是为了生存。
So is that also? where high functioning codependency comes from is at some point you've learnt a pattern of behavior that's made life easier for you by allowing you to be more in control. Is that also something that you see a lot? I do. And the thing is, it's in a way, it's an illusion of control. But it does make sense. And along the same lines, if we're talking about childhood, you might have a lot of people being parentified in childhood. So there's two different ways of being parentified. One is emotion. If you have a parent who talked to you like you were a grown-up, told you things about themselves that wasn't appropriate or shared adult burdens with you about we don't have the money to pay the lights or whatever, you know. That's one way.
那么这也是高功能共依附的根源吗？即在某个时刻，你学到了一种行为模式，它能让你掌控更多，从而使生活变得更轻松。这也是你经常看到的情况吗？是的。而且问题在于，从某种程度上说，这是一种对掌控感的错觉。但它确实有其逻辑。顺着这个思路，如果我们谈论童年，你可能会发现很多人在童年时就“父母化”了（parentified）。“父母化”有两种不同的表现形式。一种是情感上的。如果你有一个像对待成年人一样跟你说话的父母，向你倾诉不合时宜的事情，或者跟你分享成年人的负担，比如我们没钱交电费之类的，你知道的。这是一种形式。
It's almost like the emotional parentification. And then there's the actual parentification, like the physical, where you might be making dinner for younger siblings. You might be expected to clean the house. You might, like anyone who is parentified, and if you had addicted parents or alcoholic parents or parents with mental health challenges, you might have been like the only sort of adult in the room, even though you were 10. So what is this do and what does it create? It creates high functioning codependency and the abilities.
这几乎就像是情感上的“父母化”。然后还有实际的、身体力行的“父母化”，比如你可能要为年幼的弟弟妹妹做晚饭。你可能被期望打扫屋子。可能，任何经历过父母化的人——如果你的父母是瘾君子、酗酒者，或者有心理健康问题——你可能就像房间里唯一的成年人，尽管你当时只有10岁。那么这会带来什么？它又创造了什么？它创造了高功能共依附和种种能力。
Like, imagine, if you're cooking dinner at 9, you're capable. bull is hell. Imagine how capable you are by 19, 29, 39. It's like, there's like not anything you can't figure out. And when you have a childhood like that, right, it makes you very, very committed to figuring it out because the alternative is feeling out of control, is feeling victimized, is being victimized, but a lot of those things that were adaptive in childhood become maladaptive in adulthood. So we have to revisit them and go, does this make sense? Should I be doing all of these things for all of these people? Is this in my highest and best interest? Do I have the bandwidth to do this rather than being on autopilot? Yeah. I think this is a great transition into talking about
试想一下，如果你在9岁时就开始做晚饭，你能力可真强。强得可怕。想象一下，等你到了19岁、29岁、39岁时，你会有多强大。这就好象没有什么事是你解决不了的。而当你有过那样一段童年时，对吧，这会让你变得非常、非常执着于把事情解决，因为另一种选择就是感到失控、感到受害、成为受害者，但是很多在童年时期具有适应性的行为，到了成年期就变成了不适应的。所以我们必须重新审视它们，然后想：“这合理吗？我应该为所有这些人做所有这些事情吗？这符合我的最高和最佳利益吗？我有精力来做这些，还是只是在开启自动驾驶模式？”是的。我认为这是一个很好的过渡，可以让我们开始谈论
the cost, because you really introduce this to us. So what does this cost us, in but also in terms of our relationships as well. When we think we might be helping someone, we think we might be this loving, giving person, I have a feeling that you're going to tell us that maybe that isn't always the most beneficial thing. Yeah, that's true. Because here's the thing. I'll tell you a quick story. And I share it in the book, but this is what actually changed my life when it comes to codependency and high-functioning codependency in my 20s. One of my sisters was in a bad situation
代价，因为你确实向我们指出了这一点。那么，这给我们带来了什么代价，不仅对我们自身，而且对我们的关系也是如此。当我们以为自己在帮助别人，以为自己是一个充满爱心、乐于奉献的人时，我有一种预感，你接下来会告诉我们，这或许并不总是最有利的做法。是的，确实如此。因为事情是这样的。我给你讲个简短的故事。我在书中也分享过这个，但这确实是我在20多岁时，彻底改变我对共依附和高功能共依附看法的转折点。我有一个姐姐当时处境很糟糕
with someone who was doing a crack addict and she was an active alcoholic and they were living in a house in the woods with no running water and no electricity and he was abusive. So, I mean, for an HFC, it's like a five alarm fire every day and I was obsessed with like
和一个吸毒成瘾的人在一起，她自己也是个重度酗酒者，他们住在树林里一栋没有自来水、没有电的房子里，而且男方有虐待倾向。所以，对一个高功能共依附者（HFC）来说，这就好像每天都拉响五级火警一样，我当时满脑子都在想
how am I going to save her from this domestic hell? You know, like, what am I going to do? So I was crying to my therapist and bawling my eyes out and saying, you know, Bev, I've done everything. What am I going to do? And she said, Terry, let me ask you something. What makes you think you know what your sister needs to learn in this lifetime and how she needs to learn it? But do you know what's happening for you and all of this? And I was like,
我该怎么把她从这个人间的地狱里拯救出来？你知道的，就像，“我该怎么办？”所以我一直在心理医生面前痛哭流涕，泪流满面地说：“你知道，贝夫，我已经做了所有能做的事。我该怎么办？”然后她说：“特里，我问你个问题。你凭什么认为你知道你姐姐这辈子需要学什么，以及她该如何去学？但你知道这一切对你意味着什么吗？”然后我就……
obviously, no, I do not. Please clue me in. And she said, Terry, you've worked really hard to create a harmonious life. Your sister's dumpster fire is really messing with your piece. You want your pain. You want that to be fixed because ultimately you want your pain to end. She is not wrong. Yeah. That is true. Yeah. And so do you think it was an element of like in your attempts to soothe yourself and to, not to say eliminate, but to fix this like stressor for you? Because of course when it comes to very close relationships, you feel someone else's pain, especially as a sibling, especially as someone in your family, there is a bond there that is incredibly otherworldly. Do you think that actually the relationship you have with your sister deteriorated or did it get to a point of
显然，我不知道，请指教。她说：“特里，你为了创造一个和谐的生活付出了巨大的努力。你姐姐那一团糟的生活真的把你的内心平静给搅乱了。你希望她的痛苦得到解决，因为你归根结底是希望你自己的痛苦能结束。”她没有说错。是的。确实如此。是的。所以你觉得，这其中是否也有这样一种成分：你在试图安抚自己，去——不是说消除，而是去解决这个对你而言的压力源？因为当然，当涉及到非常亲密的关系时，你能感受到别人的痛苦，特别是作为兄弟姐妹，特别是作为你家庭中的成员，那种纽带是极其超乎寻常的。你是否觉得，实际上你和你姐姐的关系反而恶化了，或者说发展到了某一个地步，
her not listening to you? Because I've had this before with people where, and I've learnt this with friends where it's like you can't tell someone to just break it with their boyfriend or break it with their girlfriend or their partner because all it's going to happen is they'll just stop telling you the bad stuff. So you're actually not helping them and you're, in your attempts to fix it, like you're actually further isolating them. What ended up happening with her in that situation, if you want to share, of course. Yeah, no, I do. I read about it in the book, so I've already shared, so no problem.
那就是她不再听你的了？因为我以前在生活中也遇到过这种情况，我也从朋友身上学到了这一点，那就是你不能直接告诉某人去跟他们的男朋友或女朋友或伴侣分手，因为接下来唯一会发生的事，就是他们不再把糟糕的事情告诉你了。所以你其实并没有在帮他们，而且你在试图解决问题的过程中，实际上把他们进一步孤立了。她在那次事件中的结局如何（如果你愿意分享的话）？是的，当然。我在书中写过，所以我已经分享过了，没问题。
I said to my therapist, so what do I do then? Like, what are my options now? And she said, Terry, you need boundaries. Because remember, it was my 20s, and I was the boundaryless wonder. So I had no boundaries. And I didn't even know I could. have boundaries with my sister. I had no idea. I was like, what? I could be a good sister and do that. And she said, listen, you don't have to let her talk to you about this guy, but you can be there
我对心理医生说：“那我该怎么办呢？我现在还有什么选择？”她说：“特里，你需要设立边界。”因为记住，那是我20多岁的时候，我是一个完全没有边界的人。所以我没有任何边界。我甚至都不知道我可以和姐姐设立边界。我完全不知道。当时我想：“什么？我作为一个好姐姐还能这样做？”她说：“听着，你不必让她跟你谈论这个男人，但如果她需要你，你依然可以陪在她身边。”
if she needs you. So I talked to my sister. I said, hey, I can't talk about this with you. It's so painful and disruptive for my life, but I love you. And when and if you ever really want to get out, I'll always be your person. I'll always be your person. And she really understood. She was like, you know what? I get it. Okay. And we talked a few times in nine months, and then she called me and said, I'm ready. Are you still my person? And I was like, oh, yes, I am. Got in my car, went and picked her up. And the most important aspect of this story is that by doing that, my sister was ready to change what wasn't working in her life. Instead of her youngest sister, being the hero in her story, which is what we're doing, when we insert ourselves, when we can't stop telling people what to
所以我跟我姐姐谈了。我说：“嘿，我不能跟你谈这个。这让我感到非常痛苦，也打乱了我的生活，但我爱你。如果有一天你真的想离开，我永远都是那个支持你的人。我永远是你的后盾。”她真的听懂了。她说：“你知道吗？我懂了。好的。”在接下来的九个月里，我们只通了几次话，然后她打电话给我说：“我准备好了。你还是我的后盾吗？”我当时想：“哦，是的，我是。”我上车去把她接了回来。而这个故事最重要的一点在于，通过这样做，我姐姐准备好去改变她生活中那些行不通的事情了。而不是让她的妹妹来扮演她故事里的英雄——这正是我们在做的事，当我们强行介入，当我们无法停止告诉别人该怎么
do. We're literally centering ourselves in that person's problem. It's so, God, that was the hardest thing for me to, like, wrap my own mind around. I was like, oh, is that what I'm doing? That's terrible. But she ended up finally coming to it. She got sober. She got back to school. My husband and I helped her in an inappropriate way, but she is the hero of her own story. It's not about me. It's about her. And I loved her enough to tolerate the way that felt. Right, because that's what love is. fixing other people. Love is being like, I'll be in the foxhole with you even when you're suffering. And even when I think you could end your suffering by ending this relationship. But she wasn't ready just because I was ready for her to do it. And it stuck. She never went back with him. She never got
做时。我们实际上是将自己置于那个人的问题的中心。这真的……天哪，这对我来说是最难在脑子里转过弯来的事情。我当时想：“哦，这就是我在做的事吗？这太可怕了。”但她最终还是走出来了。她戒了酒。她重新回到了学校。我和我丈夫以一种恰当的方式帮助了她，但她才是她自己故事里的英雄。这与我无关。这是关于她的。而且我足够爱她，能够忍受那种感觉带来的不适。对，因为这才是爱的真谛。而不是去修复其他人。爱是这样一种态度：“我会和你一起呆在战壕里，哪怕你正在遭受痛苦。哪怕我认为你可以通过结束这段关系来终止痛苦。”但她还没有准备好，仅仅因为我已经准备好让她去做了。而且这次改变持久了。她再也没有回到那个男人身边。她再也没有
into another relationship like that. And that was this decades ago. She's gone on to have a career. It's like she did that herself. And we robbed people of their sovereignty. And their dignity when we're endlessly thinking we know what they should be doing. So what can we do instead? The cost to us is great to, burnout, health, bitterness, living life light is what I call it, when we're constantly obsessed and, you know, in our minds about other people and other things. We're not fully present in our own life. And life hits different when you're kind of only half here.
陷入过那种关系中。那是几十年前的事了。她后来拥有了自己的职业生涯。就好像那是她自己做到的。当我们无休止地自以为知道别人该做什么时，我们实际上剥夺了他们自主权和尊严。那么我们该怎么做呢？我们付出的代价是巨大的：精疲力竭、健康受损、怨恨、我称之为“浅尝辄止的生活”——当我们总是对其他人和其他事 obsesseed（着迷/执念）并且满脑子都在想这些时。我们无法完全活在自己当下的生活中。当你只是半心半意地活着时，生活的感觉是截然不同的。
It's like half as juicy as it should be. Half as amazing as it should. I love that way. You know what I mean? Yeah, I do. So true. And we're not fully self-expressed because we're not focusing on us. We're focusing on others.
就像只有它本该有的多汁美味的一半。只有它本该有的精彩的一半。我很喜欢这种说法。你知道我的意思吗？是的，我懂。太对了。而且我们无法充分表达自我，因为我们的焦点没有放在自己身上，而是放在了别人身上。
And then we have the cost to the other people. Their autonomy, right? Not accepting them where they are. People become projects. Nobody likes that. They do not like it. And I hate it when I feel like someone thinks I'm a project. I want to punch them.
然后，这对其他人来说也是一种代价。他们的自主权被剥夺了，对吧？没有在他们所在的地方接纳他们。人们变成了项目。没有人喜欢这样。他们绝对不喜欢。而当我感觉到别人把我当成一个项目时，我也讨厌这样。我想给他们一拳。
I'm like, hey, man, look at my life. Does it seem like I need your advice? I don't. Please stop giving it to me. It's very dehuman. humanizing, which is not what we're trying to do. So what can we do instead? Anyway, you guys who are listening, we're like, okay, great, thank you.
我会想：“嘿，老兄，看看我的生活。看起来我需要你的建议吗？我不需要。请别再给我提建议了。”这非常不尊重人（dehumanizing），而这并不是我们的初衷。那么我们该怎么做呢？总之，各位在收听的听众，你们可能会想：“好吧，太好了，谢谢。”
I'm identified. Now what can I do? Well, that's hope that you've raised your awareness through this conversation that we're having. You need to take a look at your boundaries. And when we're HFC is a lot of times we're the ones trampling on other people's boundaries. Inadvertently, we're not meaning to. but when you give someone advice who hasn't asked you for advice
我认清了。那我现在能做什么呢？好吧，希望通过我们刚才的对话，你已经提高了自我觉察。你需要审视一下自己的边界。而当我们处于高功能共依附状态（HFC）时，很多时候我们反而是那些践踏他人边界的人。我们是无意中这么做的，并非本意，但当你给一个根本没有向你征求意见的人提建议时
when you just transfer money into someone's account because you're worried they're not going to make their rent but I had a client who was paying rent for like 38-year-old son or whatever it was. Oh, man. And I was like, you know, she's like, well, just in case he doesn't have enough. And I'm like, this is what I think is happening.
当你仅仅因为担心别人交不起房租，就把钱直接转到别人的账户里——我曾有一个客户，她一直在替自己38岁的儿子付房租，诸如此类的事情。哦，天哪。当时我说：“你知道，她却说，‘以防万一他钱不够用。’”而我想的是，这背后真正发生的事情是：
Here's the subtext of that. Your son who's mismanaging his money comes to you and says, I don't think I can do it. I don't think I'm going to make it. I don't know how to do this. I think I'm a loser. You giving him money monthly?
这背后的潜台词是：你的儿子不善于理财，他找到你说：“我觉得我应付不来。我觉得我做不到。我不知道该怎么做。我觉得自己是个失败者。”而你每个月给他钱？
What are you saying? I agree with you. I agree. I think you're a loser too. I don't think you're going to do it either. Wow. And did she stop doing it? Yes, but the thing is, she changed it.
你这是在说什么？“我同意你的看法。我也同意。我觉得你确实是个失败者。我也不认为你能行。”哇。那她后来停手了吗？停了，但关键在于，她改变了方式。
I was like, the conversation isn't about cutting him off. The conversation is about believing in him. I have faith that you are resourceful. and I know that you're going to figure this out. And I don't think I've been helping you. And I'm sorry, but I honestly do believe in you, which is why I'm not going to be giving you any more money. You're 38, you have a job, you're grown up,
我当时说：“谈话的重点不应该是跟他断绝关系。谈话的重点应该是去相信他。我相信你是有能力解决问题的。我知道你能把这件事搞定。而且我不认为我之前的做法是在帮。对不起，但我真心相信你，这就是为什么我不会再给你钱了。你38岁了，你有工作，你是个成年人了，
and I want to respect that. I want to respect your autonomy. Instead of giving the auto advice stuff too, for people who are really identified, because I feel like most people, if you're a loving person, you just think that's a part of it. So instead of immediately giving advice
我希望尊重这一点。我希望尊重你的自主权。”同样，对于那些习惯性给别人提建议的人，不要再自动给出各种建议了，因为我觉得大多数人，如果你是个充满爱心的人，你就会觉得这是其中的一部分。所以，不要立刻给出建议
or having ideas or suggestions, I want you to just start to raise your awareness about how often you want to give advice, right? How often you want to add your two cents? And instead of that, if your friend comes to you with a problem, even if you eventually give them your two cents, the first thing you're going to say is,
或者提出各种想法和见解，我希望你开始培养一种觉察：你有多么渴望去给别人提建议？对吧？你有多么渴望去插话发表你的两分钱见解？相反，如果你的朋友带着问题来找你，即使你最终还是会给出你的意见，你首先要说的话也应该是：
okay, before we get into it, you tell me what you think you should do because you're in the situation. Nobody's gut is better than yours about, this because it's your life. And I'm here too. You want to brainstorm it. You want to spitball it, whatever you want to do. But it's like putting the emphasis back on them because it's the truth. Like you actually don't know what they should do. You can share experiences you had if you want to later. But I feel like it can't be the first step, the first stop on the bus. You know what I
“好的，在我们深入探讨之前，你先告诉我你觉得你应该怎么做，因为身处其中的人是你。对于这件事，没有人比你的直觉更准了，因为这是你的人生。而且我也会陪着你。你想集思广益也好，随便聊聊也罢，你想怎么做都行。”但这就好象是把重心重新放回他们身上，因为这是事实。事实上，你确实不知道他们该怎么做。如果你愿意，你以后可以分享你自己的经历。但我觉得这不能作为第一步，不能一上来就这么做。你知道我的
mean? Because now we're co-opting that conversation and bringing it back to our grade A advice instead of saying, so how do you feel about that? And then what happened? Well, what was that like? And then what did they say? Like, there's a way to ask expansive questions, and it's the most loving thing in the world to give people your undivided attention.
意思吗？因为这样一来，我们就把谈话给劫持了，又回到了我们那优等生的建议上，而不是去问：“那你对这件事有什么感受？”然后呢？“后来发生了什么？”“当时那是怎样一种体验？”“他们又是怎么说的？”——其实是有办法提出开放式问题的，把你的全神贯注给予他人，是世界上最具爱心的事情。
Especially if it's not undivided attention with the purpose of then providing advice. You know what I mean? I feel like that's really what I'm getting from this is allow people to show you that they're capable. I feel like so often we listen to someone's problems and we're concocting exactly what we think that they should do and what we would do and how we can help.
特别是这种全神贯注并不是为了接下来好给别人提建议。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得我从中学到真正重要的一点是：允许别人向你展示他们是有能力的。我觉得我们经常在倾听别人的问题时，脑子里已经在构思我们认为他们应该怎么做、如果是我们会怎么做以及我们能如何去帮他们。
Have you ever had one of those situations where someone is just ranting and very upset and you go to give them advice and you can just say they just really don't want it? They really are not interested. Actually, what they want is, as you said, for someone to listen to them. And I'm listening to this and thinking about situations with my friends.
你有没有遇到过这样一种情况：有人正在疯狂倾诉而且非常沮丧，你刚要给他们提建议，就能看出他们其实根本不想要建议？他们一点兴趣都没有。其实他们想要的，正如你所说的那样，只是希望有人能倾听他们。我听着这些，想到了我和朋友们相处的经历。
And I'm thinking about situations with my sisters where I have just jumped in and been like, okay, so I can just pay for that if you want. You know, if you're worried about, you know, my sister was talking to me the other day. And I was like, well, if you're worried about that, like, I'll just send you some money. What became really clear to me in that as well was that we could have gone in and talked for like another 20 minutes. But also because I just immediately offered that solution, I actually didn't really hear how she was feeling. and my initial reaction to just jump in and be like, oh my gosh, I love you so much, let's fix this, what can I do? Maybe that's why you're calling me. I think I realized I was like, actually,
我也想到了我和姐姐相处的经历，过去我总是直接插话，然后说：“行吧，如果你想要的话，那我可以帮你把那个付了。”你知道的，如果你担心的是——我姐姐前几天还在跟我聊天。然后我说：“好吧，如果你担心那个的话，那我就直接给你汇点钱过去。”在那一刻，对我来说变得非常清晰的一点是：我们本可以继续聊上个二十分钟。但同时，正因为我立刻提出了那个解决方案，我实际上并没有真正去倾听她的感受。而我急于插话并说“哦天哪，我太爱你了，我们来解决这个吧，我能做点什么”的初始反应，
no, you're calling me just because you wanted to be heard, not because you wanted to be fixed in a way. That's so good and it's so true. And you're exactly right. Your insights are so good because you're exactly right. This behavior, high functioning, codependent behavior, it limits. the intimacy that we have in our relationships because exactly what you just described is what we do. So how we know people is we go, so if you did know what to do, what do you think it would be? Or have you felt like this before? Like when we ask expansive questions, this is when we learn about people. And another thing that you can do that is so helpful when you want to give advice or are you not sure someone's in pain.
也许那就是她打电话给我的原因。我突然意识到：其实不对，你打电话给我只是因为你想被倾听，而不是为了被当成问题来修复。这太棒了，而且千真万确。你说的全对。你的洞察力太好了，因为你完全说对了。这种行为——高功能共依附行为，它限制了我们在关系中能够达到的亲密程度，因为我们做的正是你刚才描述的那种事。所以，我们了解别人的方式应该是这样的：“如果你真的知道该怎么做，你觉得那会是什么？”或者“你以前也有过这种感觉吗？”——当我们提出开放式问题时，这才是我们真正了解别人的时候。而你能做的另一件非常有帮助的事，当你想要提建议或者不确定别人是否正处于痛苦中时，
And even with your sister, you can always say, how can I best support you right now? 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
哪怕是对你姐姐，你也可以随时去问：“我现在该如何最好地支持你？”2%。这就是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导大健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会发现自己破茧成蝶，变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称是英文数字 TWO 加上 Percent，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（袭胸）小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of course. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
你可以通过收听《Look Back At It》播客来寻找答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请到了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为——当然是因为快克。我很乐意在节目里聊聊快克，只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆到台面上了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听《Look Back At It》，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。欢迎来到我的新播客《The Hard Way》，我是主持人、也是你们最爱的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking,
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验，与众多不可思议的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是，
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们去追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们却依然在追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间走这一遭，做一个好人很重要？还是说你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地、纯粹地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客中，让我们就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力与人生目标展开真实的对话。
learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once.
收听《The Hard Way》。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索 “The Hard Way” 并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻之中。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的自相矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的、旨在证明真相的法庭之战。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，这么说——我伪造了一次检测。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这花费了一大批互联网侦探的力量才破解了这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，这位女同性恋。迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的世界观都被颠覆了。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。
podcasts. When you want to give advice or are you not sure someone's in pain and even with your sister, you can always say, how can I best support you right now? And this comes back to the core foundation of codependency. You're not enabling them. You're no longer enabling them to see you as, I don't know, the cash cow, or see you the one who can fix it for them or the one who can plan for them. Like you said, you know, it's agency.
当你想要给出建议，或者不确定别人是否在痛苦中时，即使是对你的姐姐，你也可以随时说：“我现在该怎么最好地支持你？”这就回到了共依附的核心基础。你不再是在纵容他们。你不再纵容他们把你视为——我不知道，把你当成提款机，或者把你视为那个能为他们解决问题的人，或者把你视为能为他们做计划的人。正如你所说，你知道的，这就是自主权。
Agency is a gorgeous, gorgeous gift to give someone trust, agency, faith. And end your own, because the thing is, when we feel overly responsible for others, our own lives, internal and external, suffer. We're exhausted. You can't do it forever. And people who do, trust me, I see women coming into my therapy practice in their six or seventh decade of life. And they're like,
自主权是给予他人的一份极其美妙的礼物——信任、自主权、信念。同时也结束你自己的内耗。因为事实是，当我们对他人感到过度负责时，我们自己的生活——无论是内在还是外在——都会遭受痛苦。我们筋疲力尽。你不可能永远这样做。而那些这样做的人，相信我，我看到有些女性来到我的心理诊所时，已经步入了人生第六或第七个十年。她们会说：
listen, I checked all the boxes. We have money. I'm on a bunch of boards. The kids all went to Ivy League schools. Is this how I'm supposed to feel? Because, wow, it's really not that awesome. And they just say like it's empty. And I'm like, yeah,
“听着，我完成了人生清单上的每一项打卡。我们有钱。我在好几个董事会上任职。孩子们都上了常春藤盟校。难道这就是我本该有的感受吗？因为，哇，这真的没有那么棒。”她们只是觉得这一切空虚。而我会说：“是的，
because nobody friggin knows you. You literally built your whole life checking boxes that other people told you. Where's the way to go? Always taken one for the team. by it always self-sacrificing. No one even knows you. It is so not satisfying.
因为根本没有人真正了解你。你的一生都在打勾，完成别人告诉你该做的事。出路在哪里？总是为了团队做出牺牲。总是自我牺牲。甚至没有人真正了解你。这太让人无法满足了。
It is such a bummer. So I'm so happy that this show is for people in their 20s. Because if you guys start now, you won't be in my therapy office in your 60s. And I can't imagine I'll still be, I'd be 100. So I'm probably not going to be still to be a therapist in 100. But do you know what I mean? Like there's so much that you can do now to realize what real love and real support means that I'll hang with you even when it's hard and even when you don't know.
这简直太让人扫兴了。所以我很高兴这个节目是为20多岁的人准备的。因为如果你们现在就开始改变，就不会在60多岁时才走进我的心理诊所。而且我无法想象到那时我还在工作，我都100岁了。所以我可能不会在100岁时还当治疗师。但你知道我的意思吗？现在有太多事情你可以去做了，去理解什么是真正的爱和真正的支持——那就是，即使在前路艰难、甚至你一无所知时，我也依然会陪着你。
I'll stay in the foxhole with you, even through the uncertainty that makes me so uncomfortable because I love you, because that's what devotion is. That's what love is, is that I will tolerate my discomfort to comfort you in a real way doing something that makes you feel comforted, not makes you feel like a problem I just fixed. I think that is the most beautiful conclusion. Such a beautiful way to summarize it. And again, if you've made it this far, you are most likely as well, someone in their 20s or maybe their 30s. I think that one of the most beautiful things about having this platform as well and having people like you on is that I think about 20 years ago when they were not these resources.
我会和你一起留在战壕里，哪怕面对那些让我感到极其不适的不确定性，因为我爱你，因为这就是奉献。这就是爱的真谛：我愿意忍受我的不适，来以真正的方式安慰你，去做那些让你感到被安慰的事情，而不是让你觉得自己只是个被我顺手修好的问题。我认为这是最美丽的总结。这是一个如此美丽的总结方式。再次强调，如果你听到了这里，你很可能也是一个20多岁或者30多岁的人。我认为拥有这个平台以及邀请像你这样的人来做客最美妙的事情之一，就是我想起20年前还没有这些资源的时候。
And that's the generation that you now speak to. And hopefully as time goes on, we have this psycho education. We have this level of self-awareness that means that you're not going to be 50 or 60 and wondering why your relationships are shallow, why you feel so burnt out, why you feel so exhausted by your need for control. So even if it's confronting in this moment, think about how much time you now have ahead of you to really rewire your brain towards trust, towards healthy dependency, and to unlearn some of those maladaptive habits that you've picked up from childhood, from teenage years,
而这就是你现在正在对话的一代人。希望随着时间的推移，我们有了这种心理教育。我们有了这种程度的自我觉察，这意味着当你长到50岁或60岁时，你不会再疑惑为什么自己的人际关系如此肤浅，为什么你会感到如此精疲力竭，为什么你会被自己的控制欲折磨得筋疲力尽。所以，即使此刻这让你感到直面现实的冲击，但想想看，你现在面前还有多少时间，可以真正地将你的大脑重新布线，走向信任，走向健康的依赖，并卸下那些你从童年、青少年时期、
from your early 20s. Exactly. And I have a super special gift for your listeners that will help them if they're identified with this. So I have an HFC toolkit for you. So you just go to terrycolle.com forward slash HFC, or high functioning codependent. And I'm giving you some lessons in there, like simplify and do less. It's like a video and a PDF.
以及20岁出头时沾染上的不良适应习惯。完全正确。我为你的听众准备了一份超级特别的礼物，如果他们认同自己有这种倾向，这份礼物将会对他们有所帮助。我为你们准备了一个“高功能共依附（HFC）工具包”。你们只需要访问 terrycole.com/HFC，或者 high functioning codependent。我在里面为你们准备了一些课程，比如“精简并做更少的事”。那是一个视频加PDF文档。
I'm giving you a guided meditation, the power of no meditation, and just walking you through things that you can do to start on this journey of recovering from high functioning codependency. Not to be obviously by the book too, but I figured I would give you a free gift just to get you going. I'm going to go check that out. And please, please, pre-order, Terry's book, this conversation has been so enlightening. I've already had a look through and it just looks marvelous. There is quite honestly, nothing else like what you've written that I've come across,
我还为你准备了一个引导冥想，“拒绝的力量冥想”，一步步指引你开始这段从高功能共依附中恢复的旅程。当然不是为了打书，但我心想送你们一份免费礼物来帮你们迈出第一步。我要去看看那个。请大家一定要去预购特里的书，这次谈话真的太有启发性了。我已经看过了，看起来真的太棒了。老实说，你写的内容是独一无二的，我从未在别处见过，
nothing else that, well, you created this term. So a lot of people do not, yeah, and it's just mind-blowing to me sometimes that, you know, it's 2024 and it takes someone saying this out loud for thousands of people to come out of the woodwork and be able to identify themselves and understand themselves more. So there will be a link both to that free gift from Terry.
没有什么东西——而且这个词是你创造的。所以很多人并没有——是的，有时这让我感到震惊，你知道，都2024年了，居然需要有人大声说出来，成千上万的人才从四面八方涌现出来，能够认出自己并更好地理解自己。所以，通往特里这份免费礼物的链接，
Thank you so much. And also the book in this episode description, Terry, you have been an amazing guest. Seriously mind-blowing. Thank you so much for coming on. I really loved this discussion. Thank you so much for having me. I'm planning to come, by the way, to, oh, you're in Australia, yeah? I'm in Australia, yes.
非常感谢。以及这本书的链接，都会放在本集的简介中。特里，你是一位极其优秀的嘉宾。真的太震撼了。非常感谢你能来。我真的非常喜欢这次讨论。非常感谢邀请我。顺便说一句，我正计划去——哦，你在澳大利亚，对吧？我在澳大利亚，是的。
Yeah, so I think in 2025, I've been doing a whole bunch of interviews. And I have this group of women who are like, please come. We're going to do events. So anyway, I think by the end of 20 or 25, I'm coming. So I'm going to come for you. Oh, my gosh. I will be their front row. Front row.
对，所以我想在2025年，我会做一大堆采访。我有一群粉丝女性一直在说：“快来吧。我们要搞活动。”所以无论如何，我想在2025年底左右，我会过去的。所以我一定会为你而去的。哦，天哪。我会坐在第一排。绝对第一排。
And Australia is a beautiful place. Everyone knows. That's a reason I haven't left. It's so gorgeous. You'll get a very warm reception, that's for sure. Excellent. Well, thank you so much for having me. I appreciate you.
而且澳大利亚是个美丽的地方。人尽皆知。这也是我一直没离开的原因。太美了。你一定会受到热烈的欢迎，那是肯定的。太棒了。好吧，非常感谢邀请我。我很感激你。
Of course. And thank you so much for listening if you have made it this far. As always, if you have an episode. episode suggestion, you want to get in touch, you want to share your thoughts about this episode, you can DM me at that psychology podcast, make sure you are following along, give us a five-star review if you, of course, feel cool to do so, and share with a friend. I've already got three friends in mind who I think are going to be getting a link to this episode in their messages. So until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk very, very soon.
当然。如果你听到了这里，非常感谢你的聆听。和往常一样，如果你有节目建议，想与我们取得联系，或者想分享你对本集的看法，你可以在 Instagram 上私信我：@thatpsychologygals（或相应的播客账号名）。确保你关注了我们，如果你觉得很棒的话，请给我们一个五星好评，并分享给朋友。我脑海里已经有三个朋友了，我觉得他们一定会收到我发来的这期节目的链接。所以，在下次节目之前，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to and learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《The Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本不敢进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《The Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生了双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了特定的检测结果两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这花费了一大批互联网侦探的力量才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的世界观都被颠覆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. On the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed.
在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会发现自己破茧成蝶，变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。节目名称是英文数字 TWO 加上 Percent，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的诈骗犯约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。
I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。这是一档 iHeart 播客。品质真人保证。本集节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。